Salam alaikum entre better care to above
and sisters in the offense hope you guys
are doing well I don't know if you guys
know about a couple of days ago my car
got hacked into they used some device
and opened my doors and open my boot and
took my laptop here they didn't touch
the camera they didn't touch my iPad on
the side so I was thinking to myself
this seemed to be weird you know so I
did a post about it just to raise people
like you know there's something going on
and you know handle and learn big
lessons from that hamdullah why Allah
does things for reason you know it was a
big reminder from here this is a nice
car mashallah mercedes-benz 220 you know
mashallah
red liver sees panoramic roof Marshall
extra sunlight you know so I did this I
posted this what happen and I also said
that's now my laptop's gone I need to
get a new one yeah and I need some kind
of if probably can contribute whatever
it is yeah I've got some money if they
can add on to that contribute so I can
get a Mac because that's the one I used
specifically to edit videos you know
that's what happened but guess what
guess what this is in Ramadan in Ramadan
before you have Eve even broken you fast
in Ramadan some prophets and some
sisters some I'm gonna say some here
they couldn't help it they couldn't
assume the best it was just like nah one
excuse the self would give seven excuses
the Sabha one excuse I can't do it it's
not coming out yes sorry we couldn't do
one excuse and you know what happened
Tommy Robinson's followers I expected
from them they came to my thing you know
he's lying he got his friend to steal it
I mean take out so he guys can get you
to buy easiest commodities that are all
expected they don't it doesn't it
doesn't faze me I laugh at it it doesn't
faze me yeah but what obsess me is this
yeah is that I don't need nobody's thank
you for what I'm doing for the Dow
whatever it is well I don't need
nobody's thank you this dad don't praise
me I don't care but at least at least
give the right of your brother have some
decency give the right of your brother
assume the best in me
at least the least of the least of the
least you can say we assume the best and
may Allah bless a lot of people did and
they did more than that and a lot of
people did worse than that how you
driving a Mercedes Benz what how dare
you have some shame look at you driving
this this
you could buy yourself a laptop yourself
how dare you come and ask the shame on
you this time all kind of madness is
going along it okay and it's just a
little minority by the way the whole of
us are like this yeah well lucky the
shame is on you shame on you you know
why because this car wallahi by allah
i'm fasting this car doesn't belong to
me this is not my car
this is not my car this is not my car I
Drive it and I'm returning it back in
October this is not my car it does not
belong to me now how embarrassing is
that for you how shameful it is for you
that you couldn't assume the best the
seller would say if we saw our brother
drenched in alcohol
we'll say somebody pulled it over his
head look at the sin of the Sahaba look
at it with crunch of the 49 verse 12
Allah says indeed negative assumption is
a sin how they you man shame on you
I've been doing down for the for the
past for now for now five years I get
death threats I've went through madness
see this I don't need your sympathy why
do I keep you sympathy to yourself I
don't need your sympathy at least don't
attack and don't assume and slander me
yeah I've been doing that I don't earn
money I don't do this for the money I
don't earn money from this yeah okay and
humble others people who have always
helped me and giving me the resources
may Allah bless Tamiya and this is I
don't make money from this and how dare
you because you just look this is our
problem we look at the parent even
Tamiya said some people are like flies
they they always land on bad places
yeah they land on bad places because
they never can see the good in people
they can never assume the best in people
and this is the sad reality and this is
what's happened to today that day when
they saw it attacking this - shame on
you told robbers as well as you expected
from them yeah shame on you for your
behavior well lie all you had to do was
one good excuse
you know what brother Ali if he didn't
need it he would not ask for it we know
the buffer from what we can see we know
do you know me to be a dodgy person have
you seen me likes coming people stealing
their money doing this that no so from
what you know you know good well from
the buffer here we might disagree of
some stuff he does but he's not the type
oh you had to do is that one good
assumption and that was
too much you know what that shows the
disease in ha because this shows that
you have something against me or you
genuine generally have a disease in the
heart that when you get the opportunity
to jump I yeah see this opportunity what
you drive let me see it is how do you
come and ask this is that doobie I'm
trying to see well lucky brothers and
sisters this is Ramadan this is the time
where you should work on yourself this
is the time where you should purify the
heart every vessel sweats was in it and
you had the disease in the heart that
hatred in yourself and that's what your
vessel sweat yeah I forgive you well I
have figured me out I forgive you
not only that two months ago I was made
unemployed two and a half three months
ago I was not working I don't even have
I had the means I don't get into detail
you handle unwise I'm a provider and
recently hamdulillah I got into a
specific job yeah specific specific job
I'm delighted Bilal I mean yeah all
please don't tell her what a lot on it
no I don't like bacon nobody I work I
don't bake people I'll give me the
assister
or for my holidays I don't need a little
please belonged all those poor Natalia
so just laying you guys know that this
is a reminder fix and purify your heart
yeah fixing prefer assume the best in
your brothers well like the basic right
your brother and sister has is that and
lastly want to finish on a good note
there was a lot of brothers me a lot
brothers and sisters and that may Allah
bless them forget contributing they said
brother here it is here's the money
going buy a brand new laptop we want to
stack the rewards what Allah he may
Allah bless
not because of them doing it not because
of them contributing towards it
forget countrymen they bought outright
these good brother sisters I'm gonna say
yeah may Allah bless them the fact that
you assume the best when he saw the call
you didn't say oh look Ali you said nah
we know the Bravo he needs it if he says
he needs it that me there's a reason he
needs it
well I'm a lie bless them my laptop's on
the way and inshallah this is what I
used to edit in recording defending the
clam of Allah and every video die edit
everything that I do these brothers and
sisters may Allah bless them are gonna
be rewarded for that and in a nutshell
Baumann sisters I forgive those who did
this male a rectifier first may Allah
give you the ability to assume the best
in your brothers and sisters inshallah
and don't forget to join the DAO
movement because what
some new stuff new stuffs come very soon
on a professional level we're gonna
defend the Kalam of Allah there's a link
below
may Allah bless you guys click that link
and donate whatever you can to me Allah
granted Jenna you're gonna see the
results very soon now I've got a go
sisters
assalamu alaikum what a mental a better
care - hello it's me this is a nice car
though